most low fat diets are based on the idea
that saturated fat should be avoided
this is because in the 60s and 70s
researchers found out that saturated fat
raises cholesterol and cholesterol had
already been linked to heart disease but
saturated fat actually raises good types
of cholesterol and recent studies have
suggested it doesn't seriously effect
the bad types consumed in moderation
it's more of a neutral energy source
with no direct link to heart problems
nutritionists have often grouped
saturated and trans fats together
calling them bad fats but while these
fats might resemble each other in
appearance their effects on you are
completely different saturated fats
aren't inherently damaging but trans
fats can lower your good cholesterol
raise your bad cholesterol and cause
insulin resistance and heart problems
it's this partially hydrogenated variety
that you need to watch out for some
foods are described as healthy because
of their high levels of unsaturated fats
unlike the saturated and trans varieties
most unsaturated fats don't raise your
bad cholesterol or risk of heart disease
the right ones can even help lower them
but there are different types of
unsaturated fats and while some are
heart-healthy others can be really bad
for you if consumed in excess a typical
batch of canola oil contains a huge
amount of these questionable fats at
high doses it definitely shouldn't be
considered a health food
as it turns out low-fat diets might
actually be worse for you when people
cut out fats they tend to replace it
with sugar and refined carbs these
things have been proven to lower your
good cholesterol and make the bad
varieties even worse there is in fact no
evidence that low fat diets have any
actual benefits they were based on an
assumption that science has proven wrong
it's easy to see why people would think
eating fat makes you fat but the truth
is a little more complicated fat may be
high in calories but it actually fills
you up much faster than protein and
carbs this is why high fat low carb
diets are often more effective than low
fat diets though food advertising
continues to take advantage of common
myths about fats moderate amounts of
natural varieties can definitely fit
into a healthy lifestyle